we don't want to hurt you if you give a
lie-detector test to a man and a woman
and ask them the same questions man we
would pass them both up to a point where
it's like a I asked a woman you love
your man you love your family you love
your home you love what you built yep
all right you see Brad Pitt or Denzel
Washington or whatever standing there
would you risk everything you built with
your man just to sleep with him and
women look good open uh I wouldn't and
they don't pass the test hey you know is
they look good but I wouldn't ask guys
the same thing you know boom love your
woman the kids the huh yeah
are you you see that girl passed out
behind a dumpster
could you risk everything for passed-out
woman behind a dumpster
[Applause]
oh I do but look at her with garbage on
she looks so cute with garbage on
we're like I'm trying to like make it so
women is just like understand a little
bit of like distant sympathize it's like
we're like sport fishermen this is what
I'm saying men like to fish and sport
fishing is different from catching fish
for food you just get it you get it you
catch it and you you know you you show
your friends
because you want them to know that you
could catch fish you take a couple of
pictures so you can show people to fish
that you have the ability to catch and
then you release it back into the water
but a lot of women in here you have
boyfriends or husbands you were fish
that jump back on the boat
and just was like flapping looking at me
like
hi I was wondering they're gonna be
fishing here again next week like
yeah for other fish get off my boat
it's that how you treat all the fears
you be like oh god damn
No I'm sorry sweetie you the last fish I
ever wanted to be where now you stuck
stuck with the last fish who was loving
you and fighting hard to be on your boat
then she got comfortable and now just
instead of doing this he's like so we've
been together for a year now why do you
still have a boat you'd be like so what
you're trying to say I can't catch fish
no more
because if I lose my ability to catch
fish then you not gonna find me sexy no
more so you gotta smell fish on me so
that you know I can catch fish so you
can act right
that's like guys you meet your girl she
was a ho like had hope
like she big old booty and this and that
you gotta let her do that don't start
trying to pump her up and get a fat and
get a foul cuz that's why you like her I
don't want no woman that no other guys
trying to I don't want a woman that I
could send to the store at 2:00 in the
morning
cuz nobody's gonna try to rape her like
I go go get some bread at three in the
morning and cut through the alley [ __ ]
goes
can I talk to the junkies they don't
want a dang guys don't like
it's hard to be honest and honesty is
not the greatest thing to be it's not
it's just no one wants to hear yeah
especially a woman you know she don't
wanna hear it
damn tight but I didn't realize how
important typing was till right now
I [ __ ] up all my good typing years
calling people gay who was going to type
in class he's like me and six other
dudes won't be a second come on steal
bread Weiser go steal bread and lunch
meat from the supermarket make
sandwiches and sell of during type and
plan and now I can't tell you if you
can't type and you try to be in a world
with people who can you feel irrelevant
and you stop you know you just say hello
to some woman on internet hi and she
come back with the 7 page memo like
hello Wow like really
all those words you saw me tight hello
and I yelled it evidently out in big
letters I'm saying hello really
seriously you think I say hello yeah
really
just send smiley faces as all I do I
know smiley emoticons I know I love
though like I can't spell if I had to
spell restaurant to this thing right to
say my mom is life like if like if
somebody help my mama hostage you had a
gun to her head
it says spell restaurant you know shoot
your mother in the head I feel like I
was look at my mother like I love you to
go look at me Mom
she prior understand that I I love you
with all my heart
stop stalling [ __ ] okay alright alright
alright
alright alright alright alright our est
oh my god here's where it gets crazy
[Applause]
I never thought Mike Tyson and the
reason I say this cuz [ __ ] now
he's fighting like farmers they got Mike
fighting anybody just to say Mike we
won't see you knock a [ __ ] out
again he was so special as a knockout
artist we hated the same but he got on
the rape beef that I'd never believed
especially based on the last interview
we had with Greta Van Susteren and he
goes she goes well you have to say to
your victims Mike he goes well I wish I
hadn't really rate the [ __ ]
[Music]
and her mama I always had to be great
the [ __ ] and I'm mama whoa that is an
innocent man that's the I'm telling you
only an innocent man could be that angry
and say some [ __ ] that [ __ ] up like I
wish I had a rapist ID up in a jail for
something instead of raping a [ __ ] and
I really didn't
so that's Mike's way of like figuring it
all out and then her testimony years ago
which cut me off even without their
interview but interview solidified her
testimony he forced oral sex on me
and I said damn he made you suck his
dick that's terrible
he ate a [ __ ] that's when it was like
case case dismissed because what rapist
tries to make you feel wonderful huh I
can eat [ __ ] a long time and I've never
eaten rapey how to [ __ ] me the sharpest
shock somebody's a [ __ ] shut up
I appear later out of Lipson slide to
hood back to expose your clitoris for
maximum stimulation shut the [ __ ] up
you can't even make a mean face while
you eat boys you can
[Applause]
you cannot be enjoying this [ __ ]
[Applause]
as any woman here beginning up was he in
the Mangano nobody here your prize
Dumbo's I was on a train in a train stop
it was during like rush hour and and no
one knew why the train stopped - the
conductor said folks did maybe a half
hour delay in service a woman just was
struck and killed by the train and
everybody went there why don't you just
be honest and do what you want to do and
go oh my god this dead [ __ ] is holding
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't go too far ahead of me you ever
try to watch the Special Olympics and
and try not to be uncomfortable because
it's there is the right thing to do
and you're not an [ __ ] but the
10-meter stumble it's possible to watch
you try to you do is you're a good
person
I mean marks it said go
[Laughter]
they fell and he didn't fall but what's
this guy doing one day he didn't fall
but he didn't run cuz the starter's
pistol scared him to death so he's just
standing at the shoot at his feet to
make a move
yes we stab yourself in the foot you
know this is